sometimes crisis does drive that change
the right I mean you said that like the
approval of new HIV drugs was an example
of how system could work more
efficiently and better you can find
definitely can find some success stories
are a number of success stories that are
starting to take shape now with parts of
the ecosystem self-organizing and
operating at peak performance these are
very very often they're driven by
patients not really a surprise but we're
seeing more and more those happen and
with HIV HIV was actually a fairly
spectacular success story if you look
back to the 80s and 90s and fitzy it was
again it was the patient's it was a
patient advocacy groups that conveyed to
the FDA in particular that they were
willing to tolerate a higher degree of
risk and uncertainty with new drugs in
exchange for potentially getting access
to life-saving drugs and it was that
kind of political cover that was
provided by the patients to the
regulator's that allow the FDA to
actually develop a new first-ever
accelerated approval pathway which then
allowed the companies to be willing to
take more risk and they were
extraordinarily productive and
developing some new drugs which have
decreased the death rate by over
eighty-five percent now but in the US
your document correct what's up in the
US the death rate I mean in places where
they don't have access to the drugs for
example this was correct but there was a
global ecosystem that did eat that did
mobilize in the story